peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rentré de raymond kopa au stade de reims
avec une fille toute neuve pour le
footballeur français numéro un c'est un
test très important tous les spectateurs
ont pour lui l'oeil du spécialiste sa
cheville résistera-t-elle à l'épreuve
débuts très prometteurs comme un numéro
9 est très à l'aise autant ses
adversaires ne le ménagent gay il
prépare des buts pour ses partenaires il
est redevenu l'incomparable meneur de
jeu de son équipe
et puis tout cac lâche vie toute neuve
n'a pas tenu
pourquoi maintenant tout est peut-être à
recommencer
[Musique]
rh pour l'industrie automobile française
à vénissieux près de lyon la proche du
salon s'est traduite par une activité
redoublé aux chaînes de montage des
poids lourds bernier car le salon pour
les constructeurs se fait comme la mode
pour les grands couturiers avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ainsi est sorti des chaînes toute la
gamme européenne des camions que la
route devait conduire jusqu'à paris et
pour laquelle se sont ouvertes avant
l'heure officielle les portes du salon
[Musique]
la nouvelle mode des poids lourds est
prête
[Applaudissements]
parmi les réalisations nouvelles il
convient de faire une place à ce nouveau
lycée de reims qui n'est pas sans
signification profonde
il s'ouvre cette année où un français
sur cinq rentrer en classe cette
magnifique réalisation de l'
architecture scolaire de 200 mètres de
long
abritera 1900 élèves dans ses 38 classes
d'enseignement général son blog chimie
et physique
ces classes de musique et de dessin et
ses trois ateliers de travaux manuels
on le place au premier rang des
établissements de son genre dans
l'europe entière au congo état
stationnaire pourrait-on dire dans la
tempe d'une table ronde encore
incertaine le colonel mobutu est venu
réclamer au chef de l'état major de
l'onu le départ de léopoldville des 1700
soldats ghanéens juger par lui un désir
[Musique]
par ailleurs monsieur lumumba qui a fait
l'unanimité des leaders congolais contre
lui a été revue en effigie au cours
d'une démonstration organisée par
quelques partisans démonstration qui
s'est révélé très respectueuse vis-à-vis
des forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
quant au président kasavubu flanqué de
son premier ministre monsieur vidéo
il a tenu à présenter lui même aux
ambassadeurs de l'inde des usa de la
france et à leurs collègues
le collège des jeunes commissaires
généraux créé par le colonel mobutu
ce qui n'a pas précisément plus audi
colonel l'inde relié aux congolais
continue nara qui s'honore d'avoir été
la plus ancienne capitale du japon et
possède sept temples vieux de mille
trois cents ans est aussi la cité où
l'on peut admirer la plus colossale
statue de bronze de bouddha elle se
trouve au temple de tôle d'haji ou une
cloche elle aussi colossale appelle les
fidèles au recueillement
[Musique]
ménara possède encore bien d'autres
après et en particulier son parc où une
troupe de serre sacré vite en liberté
charmants animaux qui répondent avec
ponctualité à l'appel des troncs
à cette époque de l'année pourtant cet
appel n'a pas seulement pour raison
d'être le repas quotidiens c'est en
effet le moment choisi pour capturer les
serres qui possèdent les plus belles
ramure
[Musique]
ainsi le veut la tradition religieuse
les plus beaux bois doivent être signés
pour être ensuite offert en hommage au
bouddha
[Musique]
a kyoto qui succède à voici 1166 un à
nara comme capitale du japon
la fête de juin une autre tradition
religieuse a réuni la grande foule des
fidèles l'origine de cette procession à
laquelle prennent part des chars géants
se situe au 9e siècle la population de
kyoto et des environs étaient alors
devenus implorer la protection divine
contre une épouvantable épidémie de
peste
[Musique]
en recréant le visage classique de 1925
illustrèrent à la fois mais dans un
genre différent pour l'année gris et
vendons guen antoine salvador a évoqué
la tendance à laquelle s'attache cette
saison la haute coiffure parisienne mais
cette tendance il l'interprète avec la
nouvelle vague des créateurs d'une façon
à la fois très personnel et très moderne
souvenirs souvenirs que me veux tu
disais aussi verlaine c'est en somme une
garçonne très évolué depuis qu'elle fit
scandale voici 35 ans féminisé plus
fluide et moins sophistiqué plus simple
plus humaine en un mot que nous découvre
ici
jacques du tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hélas valter tommasi
même tendance sinon une école chez
pierre de brouilly
et chez l'ukraine ou 1925
oui mais tout de même avec le style de
1960 la chasse est ouverte dans paris et
son département
ainsi en décide un arrêté du préfet de
la seine qui lui pense et il faut donc
croire que le temps n'est pas si loin où
les noms de la butte aux cailles et de
la garenne-colombes avaient leurs
authentiques raison des ou la venue des
chasseurs comme la chaussée de la muette
autrement dit la note désigné vraiment
quelque chose de réel et où ce qui est
aujourd'hui la place de la concorde
n'était qu'une landes où louis xiv
allait encore tirer les latins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours est il que la chasse est
ouverte pour les parisiennes on imagine
ce que cela veut dire est de même pour
les couturiers des champs elysées ce qui
fait que la saison de chasse commence à
paris chez jacques esterel
la première question qu une chasseresse
se pose très naturellement ça n'est pas
que l'on nous chasser mais qu'allons
nous met il faut quand même en venir à
cette seconde question que chasser à
paris car à vrai dire on ne voit pas
très bien même avec le harnachement le
plus pratique ou le plus élégant la
chasseresse 1960 battre les guéret de la
rue de bellechasse
[Musique]
ou se mettre à l'affût dans les labours
de la rue des alouettes on ne voit pas
non plus très bien le tir au pigeon
s'instaurer place de l'étoile
alors disons que s'il n'est pas question
de prendre les enfants du bon dieu pour
des canards sauvages
il reste encore le long de la seine
quelques poules d'eau et que les avenues
sont toujours assez fréquentés par ces
cahiers tc petite voix que le langage de
la vénerie nomme cérémonieusement grouse
ou canepetière il reste aussi ces sortes
de chaud lapin que jamais n'atteignit
nul myxomatose et reste encore le faisan
race qui hantent les bars de luxe et qui
fait généralement bon ménage avec le
pigeon mais moins avec le poulet
et maintenant en jours
[Musique]
pédaler en musique c'est le remarquable
compromis entre le sport et l'art qu'on
réussisse et fringant militaire
hollandais
[Musique]
un matériel évidemment très étudié les
ya aidés
[Applaudissements]
si la bicyclette conserve à notre époque
une faveur unanime au pays des tulipes
c'est à n'en pas douter que les
hollandais on suit l'associé intimement
à l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]